Європарламент у резолюції про партнерство з Україною - 433 голоси "за", 105 "проти" -
закликав зупинити будівництво газопроводу по дну Балтійського моря з Росії до Німеччини.
Цей заклик пролунав в унісон з резолюцією нижньої палати Конгресу США, ухваленої напередодні.
Різниця у тому, що американська версія більш конкретна
й апелює до Німеччини та європейських урядів.
А ось євродепутати не пояснили, хто і яким чином повинен запобігти проекту "Газпрому".
Тому з юридичного боку це викликає запитання.
Європарламент працює в тісній співпраці з Єврокомісією, яка дуже хоче зупинити цей проект.
Однак парламент не має повноважень - і, до речі, у Єврокомісії теж -
для цього їм потрібен мандат Європейської Ради.
А цього мандата вони не отримають з тієї причини,
що німецький та австрійський уряди - твердо проти.
Експерт не приховує, що проект "Газпрому" не відповідає всім вимогам ЄС.
Своєї згоди ще не дала Данія.
Але навіть якщо Копенгаген висловиться проти - переконані аналітики -
"Газпрому" доведеться лише трохи змінити маршрут - нехай і ціною подорожчання "Нордстріма-2".
Тим часом, важелів взагалі зупинити завершення будівництва у Євросоюзу
фактично немає, каже експерт.
Я не бачу реального правового механізму завадити добудові "Північного потоку-2".
Якщо це станеться, то це буде політично мотивованою маніпуляцією правом.
І це, звичайно, не піде на користь діловій репутації Німеччини.
Але на газопровід ще можна чинити політичний тиск,
якщо США натиснуть санкціями на європейські компанії,
що беруть участь у цьому дорогому проекті "Газпрому" вартістю 9,5 мільярдів євро.
Якщо ці компанії, під тиском американських санкцій, відкличуть свою участь,
"Газпрому" доведеться вкласти в проект на 4 з половиною мільярди євро більше, ніж планувалося.
Говорячи про "Північний потік-2", який за планом уже через рік має запрацювати,
часто забувають про інші геополітичні проекти Кремля.
Приміром, "Турецький потік" прокладають також в обхід України, нагадує видання "Zeit".
"Зупинка "Північного потоку-2" принесе мало користі Україні.
Тоді "Газпром" побудує інші газогони в Чорному морі або термінали для зрідженого газу.
Або знайде нових партнерів у Європі.
Путін у будь-якому разі змінить нинішню роль України як головного транзитера газу до Європи".
Тим не менше подвійна атака на "Північний потік-2" з Вашингтона і Страсбурга
обнадіює українську владу.
Особливо в контексті інциденту в Керченській протоці.
Президент Петро Порошенко, який вирушив на час саміту ЄС до Брюсселя,
розраховує змінити позицію Берліна щодо газопроводів.
Змінити позицію Берліна хочуть і США.
Як наголошується в резолюції Палати представників США,
ухваленій напередодні, прокладання газопроводу "Північний потік-2" -
це удар і по енергобезпеці Європи, і по інтересах Сполучених Штатів.
"Геополітична зацікавленість Росії в "Північному потоці-2"
зводиться не до підвищення європейської енергетичної безпеки,
але радше до спроби вбити клин між європейськими країнами
і суттєво послабити роль наявної української газотранспортної системи".
Конгресмени закликали керівництво США застосувати новий закон
про протидію ворогам Америки, підписаний у 2017 році Дональдом Трампом.
Однак якими саме будуть наслідки для "Північного потоку-2",
на думку аналітиків, залежить від конкретних кроків Білого дому.
Наразі на розгляді адміністрації Дональда Трампа знаходяться санкції проти європейських компаній,
що мають відношення до фінансування "Північного потоку-2".
Усе залежить від різновиду санкцій.
Важкувато буде, якщо вони будуть спрямовані на технічні потужності для "Північного потоку-2"
В такому випадку "Газпрому" доведеться використовувати для прокладання труб інші кораблі,
які не під санкціями.
Втім, у Росії є власний корабель-прокладальник.
Імовірно, санкції не зупинять завершення проекту, але сповільнять його.
Резолюція містить заклик до урядів країн ЄС відмовитися від "Північного потоку-2",
який збільшить залежність від російських енергоносіїв.
Однак раніше офіційний Берлін вже підтвердив свою позицію
щодо продовження проекту, незважаючи на американські санкції.
Вихід німецького бізнесу з цього проекту не призвів би до припинення будівництва газопроводу.
Він призведе до того, що Росія будуватиме його сама.
Дональд Трамп різко критикує позицію Німеччини.
"Північний потік-2" не раз ставав об'єктом критики президента США.
Але з його боку це були в основному лише слова.
А у конгресменів нині на розгляді знаходиться близько 10 законопроектів,
спрямованих проти енергетичного сектора Росії.
США хочуть, у першу чергу, зафіксувати свою позицію несхвалення дій Росії, а саме "Газпрому".
Це критика і в якомусь сенсі покарання.
Однак вони розуміють, що нічого конкретного цим не доб'ються,
і розраховують більше на самопіар.
Друга їхня мета - в певному сенсі застерегти Німеччину
від особливих взаємин з Росією, у відриві від інших країн Європи.
На думку німецького експерта, стратегічною метою американської влади
є витіснення з європейського ринку "Газпрому",
який вони вважають головним інструментом Кремля.
Це зменшило б і надходження до російської скарбниці, і обмежило б російський вплив.
За американськими оцінками, Росією контролюється близько 40 відсотків
газового ринку в Європі,
а 11 країн ЄС отримують з Росії 75 і більше відсотків необхідного їм газу.
Як альтернативу європейцям пропонують купувати зріджений газ,
який нині здебільшого дорожчий від газу, що надходить газогонами з Росії.